now we're going to talk about five electrolytes
there are others like phosphorus and bicarbonates
those tend to buffer the ph if things are too acid
or to alkaline but i'm going to focus on these
five right here let's start with sodium sodium is
a mineral that helps hydrate things because it's
water is attracted to it and of course if you
have too much sodium you're going to retain
fluid but if you don't have enough sodium
you're not going to hydrate the cells
as well also sodium is involved in oxygen
transport so if you're getting swelling in
the red blood cells for example you're not going
to be able to carry oxygen to the body and you're
going to actually kind of run out of air so you
could have all sorts of problems with endurance
for example if you're low in sodium let's say you
uh you do this huge workout and you're sweating
and you lose your sodium you're going to be very
very tired and you're not going to be able to like
walk up the stairs because you're going to run
out of oxygen sodium also works with chloride
as in salt for various things but sodium also
works with other minerals like potassium there's
a pump called the sodium potassium pump and the
purpose of that pump is to generate electrical
potential and you can look at that as like a
battery it's basically these two are necessary
in making sure that there's enough electrical
charge inside that cell because your cells are
mini batteries they have voltage and the reason
why your body is designed like that is to power
the nerve and muscle interaction the contraction
of the muscle and the firing of the nerves okay so
if you don't have enough sodium or potassium that
pump can't work and you're not going to be able to
activate the nerve impulses or the muscles to work
so there's a lot of problems that can happen with
potassium deficiency and sodium deficiency and
you're going to feel tired and weak on both of
these right here now when we get to magnesium
magnesium controls the absorption of sodium
and potassium so this is a very important mineral
as well the most of the population is deficient in
magnesium magnesium is at the core of chlorophyll
which is in all the leafy greens an average person
consumes probably a cup and a half of vegetable
per day and they're usually deficient in magnesium
magnesium also is associated with oxygen like
sodium but it's mainly about relaxation of
the muscle whereas calcium is about the muscle
contraction so these work together to contract
and relax the muscle so magnesium is there to
also prevent cramping so when you're deficient
in magnesium you get muscle cramps but if
you're deficient in calcium you can also get
muscle cramps magnesium is real necessary in
your workouts especially if you do long workouts
or intense workouts let's say you're doing a
bench press where you're doing some type of
intense pushing motion or something that you
have to have some sustained contraction then you
need a lot of magnesium and so if you find that
you can't work out very long or very intensely
you may need magnesium or you may need calcium
i notice when people are deficient in calcium
they lose their grip strength they just
cannot lift as much weight but calcium
is also about neuromuscular excitability
so it's the nerve stimulus of the muscle
just like potassium right if there is
a calcium deficiency what can happen
is you can get too much of this and get tetany
where you have this little twitching going on
either in the left eye your arm or throughout the
body now this can also happen in the heart too
so heart palpitations really are a problem with
electrolytes when you're low on calcium you get a
muscle cramp and you'll also have skeletal muscle
weakness and then chloride works with sodium
and it has everything to do with hydration now
there's a lot of other functions of these minerals
that relate to other things that aren't associated
with the electrolytes so i just wanted to focus in
on these electrolytes for this video hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system it's a
free course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today